ahora vamos a repasar el ciclo de calvin
lo vamos a ver con mucho más detalle que
en el vídeo pasado y al hacer esto vamos
a poder apreciar una ineficiencia del
ciclo de calvin o bueno una cosa que
nosotros creemos que es una ineficiencia
que sucede en la fotosíntesis de muchas
plantas
así es que repasando el ciclo de calvin
empezamos con dióxido de carbono en el
vídeo pasado teníamos 6 moléculas de
dióxido de carbono y 6 moléculas de
rigurosa vy fosfato pero ahora para
demostrarte que en realidad ese ciclo lo
pudimos haber dividido en dos ahora
vamos a empezar con tres moléculas de
dióxido de carbono y tres moléculas de
ribó los avisos fatto por si no
recuerdas que es la riva los avis
fosfato es simplemente una cadena de 5
carbonos un poquito más complicada de lo
que la estamos dibujando pero es una
cadena de 5 carbonos que tiene dos
grupos fosfato y bueno lo vimos en el
vídeo pasado y lo vamos a ver con más
detalle en este vídeo
pero empezamos por aquí aquí en esta
molécula de dióxido de carbono lo que
realmente nos importa es que tenemos un
solo carbono ok por aquí no quiero
dibujar a los oxígenos en lo que nos
estamos enfocando es en la cantidad de
carbonos en el vídeo pasado vimos que
estos dos se juntaban nunca y
reaccionaban en la presencia de una
enzima llamada tribu los abismos fato
carboxilasa oxigenas a lo que hay es una
enzima es una proteína muy grande que te
enseñe en el vídeo pasado y sobre
aviación es rubisco así es que voy a
poner por aquí en medio del ciclo
rubisco porque todas estas reacciones se
dan sobre la enzima rubisco estas
moléculas se enlazan a la enzima en
rubisco y ahí junto con los atp y los
enea de ph reaccionan estas reacciones
del ciclo de calvin se dan gracias a
esta enzima rubisco
es que esta enzima es súper importante
porque estas reacciones se dan sobre
ella y significa rigurosa bis fosfato
carboxilasa oxigena ssa y su nombre de
hecho nos está diciendo que puede
catalizar la reacción en la que se añade
un carbono a la rigurosa bis fosfato en
el vídeo pasado no lo expliqué a fondo
no lo vimos a detalle pero dijimos que
si teníamos esas moléculas y
utilizábamos 6 atp y 6 mdp h
obteníamos glitter aldehído 3 fosfato o
sea este compuesto que abre veamos como
g 3 p que también es conocido como
fósforo visceral de ido y también se
abrevia como p gal y una forma muy
simple de visualizarlo es una cadena de
3 carbonos con un grupo fosfato en el
vídeo pasado empezamos con 6 dióxido de
carbono y 6 rívolo savvis fosfatos
y terminamos con 12 goles en este vídeo
estamos empezando con la mitad de las
moléculas empezamos con 3 y 3 así es que
vamos a obtener la mitad de los
productos porque ahí vamos a terminar
con 6 g 3 pets y si salen las cuentas no
por aquí tenemos 3 carbonos más 3 por 5
carbonos o sea 15 318 y por acá tenemos
6 por 3 que también es 18 y esto es lo
que estábamos viendo en el vídeo pasado
pero aquí hay algunos pasos intermedios
que queremos ver con más detalle en
realidad el primer producto que se forma
se llama 3 fósforo y literato
post for liderato y la razón por la que
estamos viendo esto con tanto detalle es
porque este compuesto también aparece en
el ciclo ineficiente que vamos a ver más
adelante si es que producimos nuestro 3
fósforo glee cerato que también es una
cadena de 3 carbonos con un grupo
fosfato pero es una cadena distinta a la
que tenemos por acá y esta cadena no
está lista para producir glucosa pero
bueno por aquí tenemos 18 carbonos así
es que necesitamos tener por aquí 18
carbonos por lo que se van a producir 6
de estos 3 fósforo lideratos y luego
cada uno de estos 3 fósforo lideratos
obtiene un fosfato a partir de un atp es
10 que en total necesitamos 6 atp
te ves que se convierten en seis aves
seis aves que por cierto estos atp
fueron producidos en la fase luminosa de
la fotosíntesis pero ahora cada uno de
estos seis atp les regala uno de sus
grupos fosfatos a estas moléculas de
aquí a los tres fósforo bilis de datos
así es que estas cadenas de 3 carbonos
ahora van a tener dos grupos fosfatos
incluso podemos llamarle por su nombre a
esto esto se llama 1/3 de fósforo
literato esto de aquí es simplemente 3
fósforo literato lo que significa que el
grupo fosfato está en el carbono número
3 pero ahora tenemos 13 de fósforo glee
cerato porque tenemos un grupo fosfato
en el carbono uno y otro grupo fosfato
en el carbono número 3 y como tenemos
dos entonces es bi fósforo y literato y
bueno también tenemos 6 de estas
moléculas con estos 6 atp se convierten
en 6
y ahora para pasar de estas 613 y
fósforo lideratos a los 63 p
aquí es donde vamos a oxidar a los n a
dp h y recuerda que oxidar a una
molécula es hacer que esa molécula
pierda uno de sus electrones o que
pierda un hidrógeno con todo y su
electrón así es que aquí en este paso de
aquí dos cosas van a suceder 6 mdp h se
van a convertir en 6 n a dp más así es
que están perdiendo su hidrógeno y su
electrón y por otro lado estas moléculas
van a perder uno de estos fosfatos así
es que por aquí también vamos a obtener
seis grupos fosfatos seis grupos
fosfatos estos grupos fosfatos de aquí
no se pierden se enlazan a estas
moléculas por aquí los tenemos y luego
en este paso se liberan pero en el
proceso cambia un poco esta cadena de
carbonos y de esta forma obtenemos
glitter aldehído 3 fosfato que podemos
utilizar más adelante para construir
glucosa o para utilizar como combustible
o también para construir cualquier otro
carbohidrato dentro de una célula ahora
otra cosa importante es que esto es el
ciclo de calvin o sea que es un ciclo no
todos los glicerol de y 23 fosfatos se
utilizan para producir glucosa o
cualquier otro carbohidrato la mayoría
de estos cinco textos 6 se utilizan para
volver a construir la revu los a bis
fosfatos así es que vamos a dibujarlo de
esta forma 5 gt space se utilizan para
reconstruir tres rigurosa discos patos
mientras que un g3 p se sale del ciclo y
todo esto ya lo vimos en el vídeo pasado
pero como en ese vídeo empezamos con 6
dióxido de carbono
los avisos para todos por aquí teníamos
dos eje tres pes y por lo tanto eran
diez los tres pesos que se iban a
reconstruir a las rigurosas bis fosfatos
y dos de ellos se salían del ciclo para
construir una glucosa como puedes
observar simplemente estamos dividiendo
el ciclo entre dos y la razón por la que
teníamos este ciclo multiplicado por dos
en el vídeo pasado era para que aquí
salieran dos moléculas que 3p y se
pudiera construir una molécula de
glucosa pero no necesitamos tener dos
aquí
ok simplemente podemos hacer este ciclo
dos veces así es que esta molécula de
glee será leído 3 fosfato se sale del
ciclo mientras que estas otras cinco
moléculas de glee será leído 3 fosfato
que como ya sabemos son una cadena de 3
carbonos y un grupo fosfato lo tenemos
dibujado por aquí también estos ahora
van a volver a utilizar a tps
de hecho utilizan 3 atp y obtenemos 3 a
de pez y dos grupos fosfatos ok recuerda
estos atp es le donan sus grupos
fosfatos a los glicerol de y 23 fosfatos
pero más adelante a la hora de formar la
rigurosa bis fosfato se liberan dos
grupos fosfatos y ahora si todos estos
carbonos y fosfatos se reciclan en la
rigurosa bis fosfato y vuelve a empezar
el ciclo de calvin tampoco debemos de
olvidarnos que todo esto sucede en la
superficie de la enzima rubisco esta
proteína inmensa que en realidad se
llama rigurosa bis fosfato carboxilasa
oxigena za y bueno ya que estamos en
esto hay que ver un poquito de
terminología este tipo de fotosíntesis
se llama fotosíntesis c3
fotosíntesis c3 y la razón por la que se
llama fotosíntesis c3 es porque el
primer producto cuando fijamos el
carbono y recuerda la fijación del
carbono se refiere a cuando tomamos
carbono en su forma gaseosa y lo
colocamos en una molécula sólida pero
bueno la primera molécula que obtenemos
después de la aplicación del carbono es
una molécula de 3 carbonos es este
fósforo glee cerato y de hecho por eso
es que te lo enseñé porque por esto es
que le llamamos fotosíntesis c3 ahora
todo esto que tenemos aquí es un repaso
de lo que vimos en el vídeo pasado tal
vez con un poco más de detalle y bueno
también vimos que no necesitábamos
empezar con 6 dióxido de carbono y 6
rívolo xabi fosfatos sino que podíamos
empezar con la mitad 3 y 3 y entonces
tener únicamente un literal de ido 3
fosfato
del ciclo de calvin y otros 5 que se
reutilizan para generar a las tres
rigurosa bis fosfatos pero lo que
realmente quiero enseñarte en este vídeo
es una cosa ineficiente que sucede en
las plantas esta enzima de adquirir
rubisco no necesariamente fija al
dióxido de carbono también puede hacer
que reaccione el oxígeno y por eso es
que se llama rebull o xavi fosfato
carboxilasa oxygen nasa que significa
que puede reaccionar con el carbono o
con el oxígeno ahora digamos que estamos
en el estroma de un cloroplasto y
tenemos por aquí cinco rigurosa bis
fosfato pero estos de aquí en lugar de
reaccionar con dióxido de carbono
reaccionan con oxígeno así es que en
lugar de tener por aquí cinco moléculas
de dióxido de carbono
tenemos oxígeno
entran las moléculas de oxígeno por
supuesto todo sigue sucediendo sobre la
superficie de la enzima rubisco
esta misma encima del ciclo pasado la
rigurosa bis fosfato carboxilasa oxigena
za y ésta oxigena sabes de que también
puede catalizar las reacciones con
oxígeno pero ahora cuando estas dos
cosas reaccionan no obtenemos productos
útiles que pueden ser utilizados como
combustibles o para construir otros
carbohidratos la primera cosa que
obtenemos cuando reaccionan estas dos
moléculas es fósforo literato porque
esto mismo de aquí fósforo literato pero
ahora obtenemos cinco moléculas de
fósforo glee cerato gates cinco
moléculas de 3 fósforo literato ahora
por acá empezamos con 3 dióxido de
carbono y 3 rigurosa bis fosfatos y
obtuvimos 6 fósforo glee ceratops y por
acá estamos empezando con muchas más
rigurosa bis fosfatos menos fósforo
lideratos así es que podemos ver que
esto no es eficiente
ahora que en el ciclo de calvin
empezamos con tres regulo xavi fosfatos
y obtuvimos seis que es el doble
mientras que en este otro ciclo
empezamos con cinco reeve los avisos
facto y terminamos con la misma cantidad
de fósforo lideratos así es que como
podemos observar es un ciclo bastante
ineficiente si es que por acá en el
ciclo ineficiente no estamos fijando al
dióxido de carbono
ahora estamos fijando al oxígeno y se
producen 53 post fog lideratos pero
además se producen otras 5 moléculas
llamadas fosfórico lato yo sé que su
nombre es un poco complicados fósforo
glicol ato hilos fosfórico la tos son
moléculas de dos carbonos lo cual tiene
mucho sentido porque tenemos 5 carbonos
al inicio y por acá esta molécula tiene
tres carbonos por lo que esta de aquí
tiene que ser una molécula de 2 carbonos
y es una molécula de 2 carbonos que
también tiene un grupo fosfato y como te
puedes imaginar aquí ya no podemos
seguir con el curso normal del ciclo de
calvin aquí ya no podemos construir
suficientes glitter aldehídos 3 pos
patos como para poder construir
carbohidratos o recuperar todas las
rigurosas bis fosfatos estamos atorados
tenemos aquí únicamente 53 fósforo
lideratos que bueno con estos si podemos
construir algunos glicerol de y 23
fosfatos pero las proporciones son
terribles que por cierto en las células
de las plantas no todos siempre sucede
de una forma tan estructurada pero aquí
vamos a poder producir la mitad de los
glitter aldehído 3 fosfatos que
hubiéramos podido producir si
estuviéramos utilizando el ciclo de
calvin y eso se debe a que el fosfórico
lato esta otra molécula de 2 carbonos de
aquí se está quedando con estos carbonos
de la rigurosa bis fosfato y si seguimos
con este ciclo eventualmente vamos a
consumir toda la riva los obispos pato y
no vamos a poder continuar y por cierto
este de aquí es de hecho una especie de
producto de desecho incluso tiene que
salir del cloroplasto y ser procesado
por otros órganos de la célula vegetal y
esos otros organelos de las células
vegetales que se dedican a procesar
productos de desecho se llaman
peroxisomas los fosfórico latos son
procesados por los peroxisomas
peroxisomas ahora lo importante aquí es
que cuando la enzima rubisco fija al
oxígeno este proceso se llama foto
respiración esa también es una palabra
importante
foto respiración y si estamos en esto en
lugar de en el ciclo de calvin ya no
vamos a poder continuar haciendo el
ciclo de calvin produciendo un montón de
carbohidratos y de energía porque nos
vamos a agotar toda la rigurosa bis
fosfato
el ciclo ineficiente nos estamos
acabando la rigurosa visos pacto así es
que es un proceso bastante dañino esto
de aquí le está estorbando al ciclo de
calvin porque recuerda lo importantes
que son cada uno de estos glicerol de y
23 fosfatos
y recuerda lo importantes que son estos
jeter space porque por cada vuelta de
ciclo de calvin sólo producimos un g3 pe
que podemos sacar del ciclo y utilizar
para construir alguna otra cosa los
otros 5 gt space se tienen que
reutilizar para volver a construirla
rívolo xabi fosfato para poder seguir
con el ciclo de calvin pero bueno por
ahora que en este otro ciclo por aquí
tenemos 53 fósforo literatos que no
necesariamente tiene que suceder así
pero se pueden utilizar para construir
5g 3 p s si tenemos el atp y el ndp h
necesarios y luego estos de aquí se
pueden utilizar para volver a construir
reeve los a vistos facto ahora aquí no
vamos a lograr reconstruir las cinco
rigurosa bis fosfatos únicamente vamos a
poder reconstruir tres rigurosa visos
fotos aunque hay únicamente tres y bueno
para llegar de aquí acá tenemos que
utilizar atp y enea de ph y después para
pasar de aquí para acá tenemos que usar
nuevamente atp y además dimos toda esta
vuelta a este ciclo y no sólo no
producimos cosas útiles como moléculas
de g3 p que pueden ser utilizadas para
construir carbohidratos y azúcares que
le puedan dar estructura a la planta o
ser utilizados como combustible sino que
además perdimos todos estos a tps y nh y
dos rigurosa bis fosfatos por lo que
consideramos que este proceso realmente
simplemente un desperdicio la foto
respiración es un desperdicio y hay
muchísimas personas muy intrigados por
este asunto porque si nos fijamos en un
montón de sistemas biológicos casi nunca
observamos procesos que sean un
desperdicio uno se puede hasta preguntar
oye
y la selección natural no seleccionaría
en contra de estos procesos y otras
personas piensan que esto es simplemente
un remanente de nuestro pasado evolutivo
o bueno del pasado evolutivo de las
plantas donde no había mucho oxígeno en
la atmósfera y justo como no había mucho
oxígeno en la atmósfera era bastante
improbable que sucediera esto esto no
sucedía muy a menudo pero hay otras
personas que opinan que esto fue
seleccionado por la selección natural
porque si hay mucho oxígeno adentro de
la célula ese oxígeno puede reaccionar
con tus moléculas de atp y crear otros
compuestos bastante dañinos para la
célula así es que este otro proceso
podría ser una forma de deshacerse de
todo el oxígeno extra bueno pues la
verdad no sabemos pero es súper
interesante que tengamos aquí una enzima
que puede hacer ambas cosas reaccionar
rigurosa bis fosfato con dióxido de
carbono y de esa forma obtener un
producto súper útil
obteniendo el ciclo de calvin normal o
esa misma enzima puede hacer reaccionar
al arribo los abismos fatto con oxígeno
y así fijar al oxígeno en este producto
de aquí fosfórico lato que nosotros
pensamos que es un desecho y si seguimos
en este ciclo no producimos ningún
azúcar útil y ahora lo que vamos a ver
en el próximo vídeo son unas plantas que
han logrado darle la vuelta a este
problema de la foto respiración como se
pueden imaginar esto de la foto
respiración es un asunto importante
puede ser un problema muy grave si es
muy importante que la planta produzca
muchos azúcares y por supuesto también
es un problema muy grave si hay
muchísimo oxígeno en el ambiente pero
bueno en el próximo vídeo te voy a
enseñar algunas plantas que han logrado
quitar este problema porque en lugar de
hacer fotosíntesis
es que es la clásica del ciclo de calvin
estas plantas hacen fotosíntesis c4 y
por supuesto la vamos a ver en el
próximo vídeo